so if you're interested in the state of
the country look around
what do you see how does it look is it
cleaner and prettier and more orderly or
is it less
that's been a subject we have been
focused on for a long time because it's
a meaningful measurement maybe more
meaningful than the stupid numbers you
get from wall street or washington which
really tell you nothing
for the first episode of tucker carlson
originals on fox nation we talked to
residents of chicago
who say that prosecutors there have
stopped enforcing the law and we found
evidence of it we got thousands of hours
never before and seen surveillance
footage that show what life in chicago
is like outside of the loop in the
affluent areas
it's horrifying people walking down the
street naked people being shot execution
cell in broad
daylight it really tells you a lot and
people living on the streets
in our five part series american
dystopia we reported on the vagrancy and
drug use throughout san francisco maybe
our prettiest city our cape town
we filmed drug dealers selling heroin in
the middle of the day we talked to a
business owner who'd been
bitten by vagrants multiple times and
his story was not uncommon
we know why this is happening it's
happening because of bad leadership and
bad laws
california's proposition 47 for example
along with
reckless rulings by the ninth circuit
court of appeals have allowed
vagrants drug addicts and criminals to
take over public spaces
in entire cities prosecutors no longer
pursue the small number of arrests that
still occur
and it's not just san francisco fox news
lawrence jones went down to venice beach
california in los angeles was now
completely overrun by people living
outside
this isn't camping these are homes you
see fighting
guns knives fires
drug use day in and day out you don't
realize sometimes what you're living in
the middle of
until you see some a video
and you think wait a minute that's where
i live there was a cleanup today
so how often do they do this clinton oh
this is the first one in
months this is not humane
this is not compassionate if i was a
councilman i would be down here right
now
man talking to you talking to these
people saying what are we going to do
about this man the city councilman has
allowed them not to have a rock bottom
that's venice california it's a
beautiful place it was built as a kind
of utopia with canals
now it's a disaster and that's true all
through los angeles
and yet one city council member in l.a
mike bonan is trying to make it worse
more encampments for drug addicts and
vagrants
on the west side of the city he wants to
put homeless encampments in lax
at the airport as well as in marina del
rey down at the beach and pacific
palisades
this is the end of los angeles of course
and some people understand that and
they've had enough
a petition to stop this plan now has
more than 19
000 signatures john brown is the man
behind it and we're happy to have him
join us tonight john thanks so much
for coming on so it it takes a lot i
assume you don't
get petitions going as you know a
profession it takes a lot for someone to
stand up and say i've had it i'm going
to try and stop it
what drove you to this place well thanks
tucker for having me on i mean
honestly i want to tell you why i
started the petition but i you know i
also just want to mention why i almost
didn't do it and
i'm not a professional petition maker
right i woke up one morning
you know about a month ago i checked my
email at like six o'clock in the morning
you know looked at it first thing i saw
was
something about emotion that a
councilman was putting forth
to potentially put homeless villages at
the public beaches and parks
and i you know i i thought that i would
misread it
and to be honest i know the name bone in
i know and councilman's but i'm not
really in politics i don't pay attention
too much to this stuff and so
i went on and went on to change.org i
knew that it existed i mean i don't know
much about it
and i put this petition out there hoping
that maybe we'd get like 100 200 people
that would maybe voice their opinion
about it and by the end of the day my
wife and i are sitting there with my
kids and i'm going guys
what number do you think it's at and it
was like 3 000 the next day
5 000 and just every day you know i mean
we
i can't believe that this many people um
it's not that i can't believe it but
i mean it's just astounding that we're
able to actually you know
create a place that this many people can
voice their opposition to something like
this
um and i just wanted to mention you i i
almost didn't do it
because you know my hesitancy about oh
we're going to be shamed people are
going to say
oh you're a nimby you're like all this
stuff and
you know i feel like i have an
obligation actually to my family my kids
my community to actually
say this doesn't make any sense guys
like what do you mean you're putting
this
at public beaches and parks i don't get
it
and still you know now i've gotten you
know i've put my
my hat in the ring and and we still
can't really figure out like what the
logic is behind bringing the homeless
to the beaches to the to some of the
most valuable land in the country
when there's tons of open land in
california and i know we have a
tremendous homeless problem so it's not
you know i don't think i'm not being
compassionate i think i'm actually
saying
wait a second this is a huge problem why
are we going to waste our time
looking into the feasibility of putting
i don't know
a hundred tenths in a parking lot at the
beach where tens of thousands of people
come
you know from the inner cities and from
all over la to enjoy that space
right why don't we find a place that's
more appropriate
that is going to be cheaper we can
create you know mental health support
for them drug addiction support
it just doesn't make any sense i mean
it's incredibly it's incredibly dark and
your opposition to it
is there's nothing partisan about it
you're a husband and a father and a
resident and a taxpayer and i think all
people no matter who they voted for
would agree with you
we put your petition up on our facebook
page the tucker carl's inside facebook
page
and we really hope it helps because
you're doing a great thing and i hope
many people join you
john brennan thank you thank you so much
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else